many people have been using nintendo
switch online since it launched in
september 2018.
in addition to the current membership
we'll be adding a new membership plan
as a part of this new plan's content
[Music]
you'll be able to play a collection of
nintendo 64 games
the nintendo 64 system launched 25 years
ago
i think this system gave many players
their first 3d gaming experiences
as well as intense four-player
multiplayer action
with nintendo's switch up to 4 people
can play select nintendo 64 games
locally or online
also with this new membership plan in
addition to the nintendo 64 games
[Music]
you can play a collection of games from
sega's genesis system
[Music]
this means you'll be able to play these
classic games whenever and wherever
you'd like
[Music]
the new plan will include all elements
of the base nintendo switch online
membership
as well as the ability to play the
included nintendo 64 in genesis games
this is nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack
[Music]
this new membership plan will be added
in late october
[Music]
of course you'll still be able to
continue using the existing plans
[Music]
also those who have an existing
membership plan can change over to the
new plan
[Music]
we'll share more details about this new
membership plan at a later time
including the exact release date and
pricing information
for now however we'd like to announce
the games that will be available when it
launches
[Music]
you'll be able to play the nintendo 64
game shown here
as well as these genesis games
we'll also continue adding more nintendo
64 games such as the legend of zelda
majora's mask and f0x
as well as other nintendo 64 and genesis
games going forward
furthermore we've prepared nintendo 64
and genesis controllers to ensure the
games can be played with the same style
controls from their original releases
[Music]
both can be used wirelessly
these controllers will be available for
purchase by any nintendo switch online
member
[Music]
we hope you'll look forward to this new
membership plan
nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headlights